وقع رؤساء الاتحاد الاوروبي مع الامين
العام للنيتو ببروكسل اعلانا مشتركه
للتعاون والتنسيق الامني ويعد هذا الاعلان
الثالثه بين الطرفين منذ عام 2016 يتضمن
الاعلان والتزام الطرفين بدعم اوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا ضمن الحرب الدائره هناك كما
يشكل رفع مستوى التنسيقي فيما يخص تبادل
المعلومات حول الاخطار الامنيه والسبرانيه
قال ان اتفاق الشراكه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
يهدف الى تقويه الشراكه بين الطرفين ورفع
مستوى التعاون الى افاق جديده على خلفيه
اجتياح روسيا لاوكرانيا السلطان الروسي
يريد اوروبا مختلفه ويريد التحكم في
جيرانه كما يرى في الديمقراطيه خطرا عليه
ولذلك يجب الاستمرار في التعاون واشار الى
ان الانظمه السلطويه تهدد القيم الغربيه
من خلال التسلح ونشر الافكار الهدامه ودعم
الجماعات المتطرفه بدوره قال شارلي شاب
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي ان حرب روسي على
اوكرانيا جعلت النيته اكبر واقوى واكثر
فعاليه من جانبها قالت ارسل لاين رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان العمل جاري على
الاستجابه للازمات عبر التدريبات كثيره
وتحركات عسكريه
عبد الله الشامي نظام اينا من مقر الناتو
في بروكسيل عبد الله بدا يترتب على هذا
الالتزام والاتحاد الاوروبي لدعم اوكرانيا
يترتب على الدول الاعضاء في الحلفونيتو
التي نعلم ان جزء كبير من اعضاء الحيطهم
ايضا اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي سيترتب
عليهم ان يعملوا على مزيد من الدعم
العسكريه التي تطالب به اوكرانيا في شكل
اسلحه متطوره واسلحه ثقيله اوكرانيا كانت
لا زال تطالب منذ الاشهر الاخيره من العام
الماضي بمزيد من الدعم خصوصا فيما يخص
الدبابات كذلك الاسلحه الثقيله الان هذا
الاتفاق ياتي بعد ايام او قبل ايام من
قرار محتمل لالمانيا فيما يخص الدعم
اوكرانيا بدبابات من نوع ليبرد هذه
الدبابات التي همم تمتنع المانيا حتى الان
عن تقديمها الاوكرانيا قائله انها قد تغير
وجه الصراع هناك لكن هناك ضغوط عليها من
قبل دول الحلف وكذلك الدول الاعضاء الدول
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي لتقديم
هذا الدعم نعلم ايضا ان توقيت هذا الاعلان
الذي يعد الثالث ما بين الطرفين منذ عام
ياتي قبل ايضا من ايام من اجتماعات همم
لرؤساء اركان الدول الاعضاء في حلف النت
عفوا التي ستعقد الاسبوع المقبل هنا في
مقر الحلف في النت والتي سيتاخذ فيها
قرارات فيما يخص شكل التسليح الذي سيتم
تقديمه الى اوكرانيا خلال هذا العام لكن
بلا شك كما قال همم الرؤساء سواء الرؤساء
الاتحاد الاوروبي او الامين العام للنيتو
هذا الامر يراد منه اثار الرسائل الى
موسكو بان سعيها لتغيير وجه اوروبا
وتغيير ما اسماء القيم التي تجمع هذين
الطرفين سواء الاتحاد او حلف الناتو لن
يكون ممكنا قائلين ان هذا الاعلان اليوم
يتضمن مزيد من توسيع الافاق بين الطرفين
فيما يخص تبادل المعلومات كذلك اجراء
مناورات مشتركه نعلم ان هناك مناورات ستتم
من خلال هذا الصيف همم بين دول الاعضاء
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف
النيته في مجال التبادل المعلومات خصوصا
الاخطار السيبيرانيه لذلك ستكون هناك همم
اجتماعات لكل لوزاره الدفاع الطرفين خلال
الاشهر المقبله بشكل عام يراد منها كما
قلنا اثاره الى موسكو بان ما اردته بربما
تقليل اشكال التعاون بين الطرفين لم تحصل
عليه وان العكس وما حدث شكرا عبد الله في
مقر الناتو بروكسل